I promise you that if every person here
leaves and does proper LinkedIn content
three times a day that they would see
miraculous results for their business a
year later attention is the number one
asset what is universally true for
everyone in this room regardless of
where you are on the journey within this
industry is that the far majority of
individuals humans here and companies
are not taking advantage of what's
happening in LinkedIn right now so just
from a pure practical standpoint there's
so many wants and dreams and hopes and
things that you want to happen in this
room and one of the most significant
opportunities to make that thing happen
is actually knowing how to make content
for LinkedIn and actually posting it and
actually reaping the benefits of it
LinkedIn right this second is acting
like a social network more similar to
what Facebook was in 2013 and 14 and the
land grab for BWB B companies and B2 B
to C companies that I've watched over
the last two years grow and explode and
really I won't use the word exploit but
just so everybody understands no ads
just taking advantage of best practices
to create organic reach is
disproportionately the underpriced
attention the
underutilized move of this Collective
room you can literally make videos and
pictures and run 25 to $50 $100 on
LinkedIn against employees of venture
capital
firms and reach them and not have to go
to conferences and pray that you'll run
into them in the hallway to pitch them
your startup so that leads me to the
next seed that I'm going to talk about
which is massive in this room in my
opinion especially for the people that
continue to slow their role on
incorporating new tech within their
organizations really the writers in the
room is this concept of
complacency you know I think there's a
really interesting direct correlation
with complacency and fear to growth of
business or my favorite well this is
tried and true and this is how I got
there as if that's what's going to get
you to the next place and when I analyze
this industry and I have clients in it I
I run a 2,000 person marketing agency
called Vayner media and we work with
some of the biggest brands in the world
to do their marketing both on the media
and the creative side so we've had
plenty of pitches for the brands in this
room um we I spent a lot of time pretty
much analyzing business and attention
247 and so when I think about this
actually I'm going to jump all the way
back to my opening question with the
hands I was born in the Soviet Union I
came to the US when I was three um and
one of the ways that my dad started his
American dream was getting a bunch of
side jobs one of them was to be a a
stock boy in a liquor store I lived in a
studio apartment half the size of this
stage in Queens with seven family
members when we first got to America my
dad got a job as a stock boy in a liquor
store in New Jersey he eventually became
the manager of that store and that's
where his journey began my
entrepreneurial Journey began in Edison
New Jersey um where when I was six I
started a six Lemonade Stand
franchise um really I don't how many
people here I I see there's some
youngsters in here but there's some
there's some people in my age here you
guys remember big wheels before you'd
get an actual bike I used to ride my big
wheels to the five lemonade stands I had
where I tricked my friends to stand
there all day and collect the money and
at the end of the day I would literally
ride my big wheels to pick up the cash
like I was Tony
Soprano that was my first business but
what I was doing while they were Manning
and womaning the lemonade stands was I
was making signs and trying to figure
out where to put the signs on what
streets and what trees so that people
would come and buy my lemonade and from
the age of six when I did that to the
second I stand in front of you right now
at 47 for the last 41 years all I've
really done was try to understand where
attention is and try to understand what
to say in it if you understand that
you'll understand the rest of my story
which is at 14 I was making $2 $3,000
weekend selling baseball cards in the
malls of New Jersey and I don't know
about you I know there's a lot of salese
and business people here but when you're
14 and you're 14 in 1989 pre- internet
and you have $10,000 in cash under your
bed and you're not selling weed you're
awesome so so that was I was crushing it
I thank you I was crushing it I was
feeling good and then my dad ruined my
life oldest son the only one born in the
Old Country turned 14 and now I have to
go work in what is now my dad's liquor
store a small store in Springfield New
Jersey and I went from making $2,000 a
weekend to making $2 an hour bagging ice
in the basement for 14 hours a day I was
just bagging ice for 14 hours a day two
bucks an hour was the worst finally I
was 16 and I was finally allowed
upstairs and when I was stocking shelves
my life changed again because I realized
on one faithful day that people
collected wine not just drank it and I
thought that was the cool cuz I was into
collecting comics and cards and all that
stuff and about 1617 I decided that I
wanted to build the biggest wine store
in the world for my dad that was going
to be my passion and this is when the
story starts to make a lot of sense for
this room my great fear in this room is
that a lot has happened in this industry
over the last seven years with
technology I think we can agree with
that right if you start looking I kind
of did a lot of homework for this talk
start looking at the mid 2015 that kind
of area a lot of you in this room
started to find finally make a
transition from paper to technology
right and then obviously Co sped that up
for a lot of people in the industry but
Co also did the thing that we're dealing
with now which is it created an
artificial growth which is why we're in
an artificial Valley right now and we're
all dealing with that and I'm sure
a lot of you are thinking about that
what I'm worried about for the business
owners in here that are considering
technology is there's multiple things
going on right now the Market's
tougher AI is looming real talk like no
matter what you've read or what you've
thought I just want to remind how many
people here are over the age of 45 raise
your hand for everybody who just raised
their hands you lived a full childhood
before you went on the internet like I
did I went right through high school
never being on the internet we have all
if we're over 45 in our grown-up life
young adult life have watched technology
completely change the world my first
ever talk was for like 13 people in
Union New Jersey at a chamber of
commerce event in 1997 when I told them
that I was going to build a website on
the information superhighway on the
worldwide
web and I was going to sell wine on it
for my dad's liquor store and I gave
this passionate rant of what was
happening and why this that and why some
of you I know all of you are advertising
in the Yellow Pages remember that o
ge's
kids you have no idea how crazy the
world was pre- internet and and
I gave this talk and I'm done and I feel
like I fully laid out why the internet
was going to be big and I felt amazing
and literally those 13 people laughed
directly in my face the first guy raised
his hand and said you're telling me that
I'm going to go to a
computer and buy a bottle of wine why
wouldn't I just go to your store
and then everyone laughed and I looked
at all of them I said all of you are
going to laugh right now and then
someone like me is going to go into your
industry and make all of you
cry and then I got
quiet and then it
happened what I'm worried about is when
I was doing my homework how many people
still have an advanced their Tech stack
and I get why I come from small business
I grew up with a father where every
dollar mattered and I so I get that in a
tough year it's hard to unravel all your
legacy Tech and make the investment to
cloud-based SAS this and this that and
retrain all your o i I promise you I'm
from the dirt I really really genuinely
understand the problem is we have a
perfect storm of why you get
hurt macro Market tough macro technology
train coming very fast you try to hold
off for another year or two cuz you want
this year's p&l not to be a
disaster and then we wake wake up in
2026 and 2027 and it's really ugly that
concerns me and that's why I talk about
complacency everyone's my favorite
strategy to watch in business is this
one this is the one that I've watched
when the internet came along this is the
one that I watched when blogging came
along by the time social media came
which is why I'm an investor in Facebook
Twitter Tumblr all these companies very
early on was I had seen the pattern
recognition your industry all of you are
going to be wildly impacted by AI you're
also going to be wildly impacted by the
blockchain don't let the greed and the
Ridiculousness of nft Summer confuse you
of what's going on in the blockchain a
decentralized server that is owned by no
one that is a ledger that is fullprof
and non- manipulatable and zero cost is
going to be where every contract on
Earth sits
all of them it's really going to happen
by show of hands how many people here
know what a deep fake video is raise
your hands put up the lights I just want
to see first of all Epic good work for
the ones that didn't raise your hands
don't feel bad it's still an emerging
Tech but clearly either that weekend
Drake song or or the Dame Lillard ESPN
thing last week so just for everybody to
fully understand for the last 100 years
of society the judge and jury has not
been the Supreme Court in America
the judge and jury of our society has
been video
proof right think about history history
will always tell you the future there
were human beings that used to live
without video didn't exist it was
invented it's not even that long ago for
the last 100 years all proof has been
the video proof we are entering into a
new era of technology and society that
every person in this room in 5 years
will not leave a single video they see
there will be more fake videos on the
internet and on the news in the next
half decade than real videos during that
same period of time think about that so
what's going to happen is every company
that produces video will first have to
put it on the blockchain to show they
were the people that made the video and
then it will go to the Internet we now
take the internet for granted it is
infrastructure for this world it is the
biggest thing that happened to this
industry in the last 25 years and
there's not even a close second but it's
only 25 30 years old in the form that it
is today we take for granted that there
won't be new technologies that come
along the blockchain and AI together
over the next 20 years how many people
here plan on being plan on working for
another actually Let Me Go a different
way how many people here plan on
retiring in the next 5 years and I don't
mean you're going to crush it next year
and buy an island I mean you're
old and you're
finished raise your hands retiring in
the next 5 years raise them all right
let's clap it up for these 14
ogs enjoy the fishing get that
Sunshine for the 99.9% of the rest of
you this stuff is coming and what I'm
concerned about is it's hard to run a
marathon when you're not on the
treadmill setting up for it the thought
of how many people here are still in the
same Tech stack or not even in a tech
stack in
2024 knowing what the world's going to
look like in 2030 is petrifying to me 14
people in here are lucky cuz they're
going to be fishing and laying on the
beach but for the rest of you if you
feel like you're a step behind on
Tech look on the record I don't like
Tech I don't like Innovation I wish
nothing changed every 5 years I figure
it all out start crushing and then the
changes I'm
annoyed I understand I don't want
anything to change I wish it was just
emailing Google AdWords like in 2000 I
had it fully figured
out I wish it was before internet my
direct mail and newspaper ads crushed
I don't want this I'm not a futurist I
don't think this is cool I Haven even
known a computer until I was
19 I'm actually not that interested in
Tech I'm just interested in not going
out of
business I'm just interested in growing
I'm just interested in not being
delusional when I said this is most
people's Tech and Innovation and
marketing strategy I mean it most people
when they see new come put their
head they see a huge t tile wave of
innovation they put their head in the
sand and pray and a very few amount of
people grab a surfboard and ride it
there are people in this room that if
they understand what I'm talking about
have the ability of correcting the fact
that they've been behind in their
competitive set for the last 10 or 15
years and they can leap frog everyone if
they were willing to put in the 50 hours
of
research on actually learning what's
happening in Ai blockchain and and this
is results tomorrow LinkedIn
content for your business you can
literally reach everyone everyone so
many people's agendas here today is to
do business development right you'll
listen to my talk but what you're
worried about is what's going to happen
out there and what's going to happen
tonight that's why you're here that's
the actual business the fact that I know
that scales 365 days a year if you spend
the five or 10 hours to do research on
how do I make good LinkedIn content by
the way there's an incredible website
that will tell you you everything you
should do I know some of you are taking
notes I'll spell out the website for you
g o o GE thank you for doing that that
made my
warning you can literally type in how do
I make LinkedIn content for an insurance
SAS company enter and get obnoxious
amount of results with best practices
this isn't about when I talk about this
stuff they're like Gary but how do I do
it that's like saying how do I get into
shape
everybody here knows how to get into
shape it's called stop eating and
go to the
gym doing it is
hard I promise you that if every person
here leaves and does proper because
there's the right way to do push-ups
versus the wrong way does proper
LinkedIn content three times a
day that they would see miraculous
results for their business a year later
the first 6 months will be terrible a
month in you'll be like why did I listen
to that guy it won't happen cuz
you don't know what you're doing yet
it's like everything you didn't know how
to swim as good as you did later ride a
bike your first kiss was a
disaster right you got better and so
when I think about this talk what can I
universally talk about I can universally
talk about content I can't encourage the
startups looking for Capital the BWC
players the people that are like
literally instead of
cold calling or preing or business
developing your way into getting to a
third party to put your insurance
into right like when I check out on a
website do I want to buy that insurance
those bis Dev deals are big I get it I
know how it works I also know that
almost everyone in that sector is not
producing content for the e-commerce
retailers to make them consider them
we're fully reliant on sales when
marketing and
brand always Beats sales I love sales
I'm a Salesman but let me explain to you
what sales is it's what you do when you
don't know how to Market and
brand I need everybody to hear that and
I'm very aware of how people look at
sales and marketing people love sales in
this room it's black and white Johnny
got the gig he brought home the bacon
yay Johnny even though he's a
we'll talk about culture in a
minute but what we don't understand and
we think marketing is a waste what did
that video do for us what's the ROI
everyone wants to be so last touch
attribution row as CAC it's fine it
allows marketing and brand to win almost
every piece of clothes that everybody is
wearing here is not because they sold
you and called you on the phone it's
because they built a brand and you want
to wear it marketing and brand works
there's a lot of big brands in this room
you see what they put out you think
they're making these silly commercials
on TV for their health you think it's
not working you think they're spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on these
videos to put out to the world and
distributing them because it's funny
they like it it's ha haa promise you
it's not it's called business and I
think for even the smallest people here
two Founders who started their SAS
business today and are here hoping to
stumble into a VC who will give them
Capital during a very hard Market even
for that early stage company all the way
to the top five brands in the building
that are billions of dollars in market
cap understanding how to be a
contemporary marketer AKA how do you
make content for this this is the
television and not for long by the way
all of you that like hate that this is
like you hate that your kids are on
social all day wait till they sit in a
pod on VR for the rest of their lives
you know what this is this is the
Beeper remember the Beeper I know you do
you loved
it a lot of you didn't get a smartphone
back in the early 2000s cuz you were
like I don't want anyone calling me
whenever they want I got my beeper they
got my pager they'll hit me up and I'll
call them when I want to talk to them
right and then my favorite let's talk
about why people resist new technology
when this thing came out I called my mom
who's the greatest I called her and said
Mom this thing is going to change the
world and then I went out and I was
speaking then and putting out content
and I would say who's getting one of
these and too expensive why and you know
why because you guys loved your
Blackberry you know why you loved your
blackberry you needed to touch the
buttons cuz you knew how to type without
looking how many people here rocking a
block a Blackberry with us right now
nice two all right I need to see it I
got to buy it from you and sell it on
eBay as a
antique we always here here's one thing
that I would like to really land with
this
group that I think is like an easy
sentence to remember
that may stick in two years and four
years and 5 years and help you make a
decision I believe the business world
and I believe humans in general are
obsessed with
no it's
safe they're obsessed with or I can
either do this or
that I really believe the most important
word for almost everyone in this room is
maybe when new stuff comes instead of no
for the stuff I'm talking post three
times a day on LinkedIn your business
will grow do you know how many people
here no can't why
no I've tried it didn't work you tried
but you
sucked right you know what the ROI of a
basketball is for LeBron James billions
of dollars you know what the ROI of a
basketball for me isga 10,000 I've torn
both my meniscuses and haven't made a
dollar on it social media link in B2B
marketing works if it doesn't work for
you it's cuz you're not good at
it and these are the things we need to
understand maybe
maybe there's so many major things going
on in the world right now from a
technology standpoint that the biggest
thing that I need to get to is get you
into understanding the analogy I made 5
minutes ago you will not be able to
compete in 5 years no matter who you are
in the chain right now if you do not up
your
and financial investment into
understanding Tech it's just the way it
is it's now
oxygen please I get it Legacy stack pull
out new high cost high anxiety my dad
doesn't my dad has had the same POS
register system in the liquor store for
the last 25 years I call him every day
trying to get him to unwind it it's
holding him back but he doesn't want to
do the capital investment and even more
train training the whole staff it's too
painful it's got a bunch of old dogs I
understand old dogs I get it and I don't
mean old in age just stuck in their ways
you could be 27 and you've been doing it
for 5 years since 22 and that's old dogs
so I highly recommend everybody heed the
call that I'm making this morning and
understand how significant the change is
that's coming I think the things that
are
practical really fall into the sea of
content which I touched on and I'll get
back to it a little bit later and now I
want to talk about one other thing that
I think really resonates across the
board in this room
culture so there is an incredible thing
going on right now in the world which
is people have
options for a lot of us that grew up in
the 80s 90s two even 2000s when we were
22 23 the reason you know how everyone
wants these gen zers to take jobs
it's cuz we did I get it it we didn't
have
options we've got to really start
talking about culture in our
organizations how many people here are a
boss uh and whether they're direct
reports or they have reports underneath
them to their direct reports how many
people here in essence manage over 10
people raise your hands raise it
high great this is really important I
think we're going through no different
than the technology shift and the big
one was the internet obviously in the
late 90s and now the big one that's
Brewing is blockchain and AI I believe
the biggest shift we're going through
right now as businesses in this room is
even bigger than the Innovation it's the
requirements to be a successful
organization from a culture standpoint
in 2023 and I know this is on everyone's
mind it's on everyone's mind because
people are dealing with remote
work I mean I would say 50% of my
employees that work remote probably work
one hour a day it's tough we're dealing
with that right we're dealing with what
a lot of us deem as
entitlement two days ago there was a Tik
Tok video that went super viral because
a young woman was talking about how
unacceptable it was for her to be
commuting to work that didn't land with
Gen X super
well but here's the problem we can sit
here and on the emerging generation
or we can understand the
truth there is a lot of people in this
room that if they were born in a
different era
when they were 22 or 23 would have not
chosen a minimum wage job that sucked
they would have just built their
business or their brand Direct on Tik
Tok or LinkedIn or somewhere else these
kids are not lazy they have
options they don't want to make 47,000 a
year doing something they hate they know
they can make 47,000 a year selling
T-shirts because of three viral Tik
toks we not them need to adjust
we to build huge organizations need
continuity people are starting to get
other options there's a lot coming there
are people who are going to be able to
write policies in a second that don't
even know this industry by pressing one
button on AI in three years that's
coming I could be in the insurance
business in a week with today's
Ai and I'm saying that obviously a
little bit ad lib but it's not as far
off as many people in this room think
well
my institutional knowledge that I've
built my whole life is being
commoditized this is a wild time and I
just highly recommend you take a step
back and think about this not only from
a business leader standpoint but from a
parenting standpoint the world parents
and manages and runs governments and
companies predominantly weaponizing
fear you want to know why everyone's
anxious fear is the currency of our
world we're going to cancel you or shame
you we're going to call you bad we're
you're going to get fired sales teams
know those numbers are up there the
whole time right if you don't hit your
number like think about how you par how
many people here are parents raise your
hands think for a second of the things
that come out of your mouth if you you
better not fear by the way it works in
the short term it works in the short
term the problem is it doesn't work in
the long term it leads to massive
resentment it leads to underperforming
I am stunned literally stunned by how
people have not figured out that nice
guys finish
first we've been sold a bag of
for most of the people in this
room the profit and growth in your
business is not about the first part of
my talk it's about the second yes do I
believe you need better tools I do I
don't even understand how one could
debate it I know why one isn't doing it
because they don't want to have the
financial thing happen this year or next
year the problem is you're digging your
hole deeper so I think that's very easy
to understand for this audience if you
have a half a
brain where your growth is going to be
is continuity and growth of your people
when people are happy they perform
better not when they're scared we have
done an atrocious job in business over
the last 70 years to play a game that is
not sustainable and is about to hit a
Tipping Point because not because
they're entitled and Rel easy but
because they have
options what that dude that made fun of
me about buying wine on the internet
didn't understand was buying stuff on
the internet is a better option than
going to the store because what I know
that you know is we pay for
time time is money you know many people
here buy coffee on Postmates and Uber
Eats and pay $13 for a coffee to come to
their
house it's
insane but we do it we take an Uber you
know how much money people waste for
convenience and choice you know how many
streaming services you're currently
paying for that you don't
use it's what we do right and so I
highly recommend and I saw so many of
your hands go up which makes me super
happy if you are managing people just
ask yourself simple questions real talk
not delusion do you think they like
you
do you make them feel safe because I
promise you what is the train that's
about to hit all of us in the next 5
years is not just Ai blockchain and more
social media advancements it is the
culture within our organizations are
going to be a very big deal and I I want
everyone to understand as I'm talking I
am not sitting up here talking fofy
foofy Grandma stuff and its feelings and
we're all soft I'm talking about making
money
I'm a
businessman I call my organization the
honey
Empire we will win because we will treat
each other with honey versus vinegar
internally but we're building an empire
that is not a soft word I'm trying to
buy the New York
Jets it's
expensive mainly who's a Jets fan in
here raise your hands all right first of
all I love
you yeah it's hard out here
so I've been trying to buy the New York
Jets for the last 35 years mainly
because I don't trust it I want to win a
Super Bowl and I only trust myself to
get it done so thank you
so so when I talk about this part I'm
always worried that the hardcore
business person here is like I'm going
to check out and look at my iPhone real
quick while he's talking about this
because this is and I know why
people think it but the data is so clear
actually how many people here like
football and know it a little bit raise
your hands I'll use the analogy if good
good enough good enough because I want
to use it
anyway an offensive line the people that
protect the quarterback if those the
data shows that if those five guys don't
get hurt in a season and have continuity
that the team massively
overperforms that's how I think about
employees we have long operated and led
with fear which actually leads to to
lack of retention more importantly a lot
of you say wait a minute like some of
you are being real with yourself right
now and say I'm not the greatest but
he's wrong my team's been with you me
for a long time it's because they don't
think they have options your team that
is willing to take your not niceness is
insecure and lack self-esteem that they
can do it somewhere else and are
underperforming and you're getting a 60%
version of them right now and you think
you're winning cuz there are still there
all retention is not
equal my friends you want to leave with
something you want to note something
down in your head or in your
notepads all retention on your team is
not
equal if your whole team's still there
but you're not setting the tone from the
top they're performing at 60% and your
little bursts of fear every quarter
maybe is creating something a little ARB
but it's just not winning and so yes
what am I saying I'm saying it's time
for all of us to be nicer to our
employees
is anybody ready for
that okay you're not ready for
it it do whatever you
want I really really believe this I
really believe in that and so that is
pretty much the essence of this talk
which is if you've been in business how
many people have been in business for
over 20 years raise your
hands all of you know should
changes right you didn't you know you
didn't expect Google AdWords 20 years
ago to build up Brands you never heard
of that are much bigger than the brands
you grew up
with you didn't expect that silly thing
I remember four years ago even after all
the success I had and all the following
I had I was yelling and screaming four
years ago that Tik Tok was going to be
next and everybody laughed at me out of
the room in the comments they're like
that's for teenage girls dancing I was
like Facebook was for college kids now
the only people are on Facebook are your
parents
people don't get it they think things
won't change because they don't want it
to
change people don't think things will
change cuz you don't want it to change
cuz you understand how to do it
now I I get it I've been managing people
since I was
22 I'm not I and I love HR so I do a lot
of one-on ones I get it for all the
bosses here I'm not enjoying these
15minute sessions where I'm a therapist
therapist and their mother and father I
get it entitlement and delusion is not
fun but things change and we have to
change with them I believe you'll have
less of those meetings if you fix the
well not the sink the last 15 minutes
has been about the well do you actually
care about your employees or are they
faceless at the end of the day trying to
hit a number let is a very profoundly
honest question that you have to ask
yourself and wherever you sit on that
pendulum because it's not going to be
one or the other you need to care more
your caring more will directly impact
your
wallet it also feels better by the way
you'll like it I promise you'll you'll
learn to like it you'll get better so
that's that I want to go back to content
because I want to leave with tactical
things before we get out of here I want
to I want to talk about the LinkedIn
thing I'm going to bash it into your
head one more time before I get out of
here this LinkedIn thing is crazy
this LinkedIn thing is crazy thinking
about the people trying to raise Capital
thinking about the people that are
trying to get bis devb deals think about
all the people that have unlimited
salese trying to get into organizations
and get them to buy I just couldn't push
you harder to understand how big of a
deal this is now you have to be good at
it which is why I want you to do it for
a while but for anyone here actually how
many people here are posting every day
on LinkedIn for their business ra your
hand
11 good it's good I just really want if
I ever get lucky enough to come back
here in two or three years I just want
70 80% of this room to raise your hand I
promise you if you happen to be sitting
next to someone who raised their hand
and you don't know them I highly
recommend you ask them what's going on
and I have no idea if they're good at it
or not because it is a game of being
good at it but if they're good at it
they will explain and give you a story
of a direct correlation of them hiring a
good employee from a competitor because
of one post a story of getting a new
client because of one post a story of
getting asked to be on a podcast because
of one post that then led to
business the world is changing we all
understand that but it's changing faster
than people
realize I all my content and I do have a
lot of followers like the intro said and
a lot of them are international for for
the people that stood up earlier from
all the countries around the world all
of my
content in
2024 will be fully translated to their
native language so I have a huge page I
have a huge following in Arabic I have a
huge following in Portuguese in Brazil I
have a huge Spanish following I have
Gary V espanol and Portuguese and all
that and all that content today is me
talking and then
subtitled every piece of that content in
2024 will be me speaking in that native
tongue fully in my voice because of AI
and AI to my lips so it doesn't even
feel weird dubbed it will be as I'm
talking we are really going into a new
era and so what I what I ask is this as
I wrap
up if you came to this conference you
didn't have to if you came to this
conference my belief system is that
you're ambitious that you're hungry that
you're still
growing I don't understand that you
would be willing to shlep to Vegas for a
conference for a couple of days but you
aren't willing to spend 10 hours of real
research on every new
trend instead of taking one headline you
read about AI or one friend saying
something and taking it as your own and
your belief system why not actually
Google how do I use AI in Insurance deck
enter how about 10 hours of research per
every new thing whether you believe me
or not on LinkedIn content can double
your business if you become crazy about
it why not spend 10 hours of research
over a week or two or three in putting
in how do I make content that works on
LinkedIn my industry again a lot of you
VCS VCS in this room good deals are
competitive good deals are competitive
the reason I for a decade got access to
all the best tech deals in Silicon
Valley was cuz I had a personal brand I
didn't compete for them they came to me
sales verse Marketing sales you have to
go and ask marketing it comes to you
your personal content and by the way as
I wrap up not everybody has to do video
this whole notion yes video works video
is a monster we watch videos it's what
we do but for the people in here are
saying man I want to do it but I don't I
feel self-conscious on video
two things on that one once and for all
can we put this to bed anyone here who's
not posting because they're worried
about Judgment of others strangers and
Friends making fun of them who do you
think you are somebody leaves a comment
saying you're ugly or stupid or wrong I
just really need you to hear this
forever more please remember this if
somebody comes to your profile on social
media and takes the time to try to take
you down you shouldn't feel bad for
yourself you should feel bad for them do
you know what kind of life it is to
go around the Internet and try to make
other people hurt because you're so hurt
inside once and for all we've left
middle school you're all grown now don't
let Johnny pants 97 leaving a negative
comment stop you from growing your
business are you in
[Applause]
[Music]
please Jesus second point on
that you don't have to do video some of
you are incredibly talented writers and
in written form you can get across what
you want to the industry much better
than you can with Gift of Gab some of
you are good with Gift of Gab but no
matter how much I try to encourage you
here you still are self-conscious
visually or things of that nature then
fine don't do a video do audio record it
on your phone and upload it as just
audio with a title my friends the
Battleground for the world is happening
out in social media content for this
industry
you have a gift it's called LinkedIn
LinkedIn as many of you remember 15
years ago was a recruiting tool it was
not a social network you all now know it
is a social network you consume content
on it you need to be part of that
conversation it's how you can easily
Garner better talent to join your
organization I think it's a huge
recruiting tool and you know this the
industry is going through consolidation
right now so whoever here goes on the
offense and has growth next year you're
going to be able to hire quality people
there's people in this industry looking
but you must not allow the tension of
today confuse you for everyone who is
really about that entrepreneur or
business life you actually know this is
the time to go on
offense if you look at any growth curve
of any business these are the best times
to go on offense when seemingly people
are on defense and they are on defense
offense comes in a lot of forms to wrap
it up one your culture
like you want to win more have a
20-minute coffee with employees all of
them one by one and actually know them a
little bit you'll be stunned what that
will mean for your business allocate the
time to
content you must make a commitment to
this content game it is a big deal and
three complacency meaning eliminate it
you praying that it's not going to
happen doesn't stop it technology and
Innovation is undefeated against our
subjective want wants and needs as
individual humans it doesn't matter that
you didn't like it it happened and it's
happening in a big way and it will
impact this industry in a big way and
for a lot of you if you get on the
treadmill now it won't be as bad to run
the marathon in 5 years I don't need you
to become Steve Jobs I need you to start
dabbling a little bit to protect
yourself from the acceleration of the
next
decade thank
you thank you
[Music]
oh